what up london
are you in charlie dating
landon barker was tight-lipped the other
night but a source tells e.t yes he and
charlie dimiglio are dating still the
pair is in the early stages of their
romance i'm hanging out with my friends
just like having a good time i've been
really happy what's up london what's up
are you doing man how's everything
last week charlie and landon fueled
relationship rumors when the couple who
are both 18 was spotted out at charlie's
older sister dixie's listening party in
west hollywood speculation that these
two were a thing kicked off earlier this
month when landon and charlie were seen
leaving his dad travis barker's concert
and now our source confirms charlie and
landon are enjoying each other's company
quote things are new between them but
they have a lot in common and are having
a good time like it is the best time
ever i think we have a lot of fun
eagle-eyed fans have been keeping tabs
on this would-be pair for a while seeing
as they run in the same circle of
friends and they both got tattoos by the
same artist in la recently this is
seemingly landon's major first
relationship since 2016 when he was
linked to social media star divinity
perkins
and charlie of course previously dated
fellow tick tock star chase hudson aka
little huddy little huddy is
your can we okay
where is he this weekend he's home he's
in l.a yeah
back at his house
after months of speculation in the early
days of their online fame they went
official in december of 2019.
i'm taking it as slow as humanly
possible okay before i pop the question
okay but we are very exclusive and very
into each other and while the
relationship only lasted until april
2020 it seems pretty serious he's a
really really sweet boy
your first on camera interview about
your love life it's something isn't it
crazy a little bit
yeah charlie was shy to talk about it at
the time but according to chase she's
the one who made the move to go
exclusive she's just like hey or do you
want to be exclusive is like that that's
what she said to me i was just like yeah
okay
and she and she was like okay so she
asked you yeah it took a long time
because at first
it was just like eh this is like fun
poking jokes and a little bit of
flirting here and there and then it
really took off later now we'll have to
wait and see what details charlie and
landon spill about how they got together
but in the meantime we'll keep an eye on
this budding romance
[Music]
you